welcome back to CBS morning's election
day 2022 is just six weeks away at this
point and some states voters are already
casting their ballots according to the
latest CBS Battleground tracker poll
here's where a thing stands Republicans
are still very likely to recapture the
House of Representatives but Democrats
do have some momentum there over on the
Senate side that remains a true toss-up
with close races all across the country
so what should Democrats be focusing on
between now and November let's talk to
an independent about it Senator Bernie
Sanders of Vermont is here Senator good
morning good morning great to be with
you I sat down just the other day with
Rick Scott a Republican senator uh and
he talked a bit about the Republican
priorities they are uh saluting the flag
learning that America is great education
uh they don't want people asking about
race or ethnicity on any government form
that's their second priority immigration
is for crime is third on immigration
they want to build the wall and they
want to end what they say is immigration
without assimilation that's the
Republicans where do you think Democrats
need to be well I think what Democrats
have to recognize is that right now we
are living in a society where the people
on top billionaire class is doing
phenomenally well and working people are
falling further and further behind so we
need an agenda that speaks to the need
of working needs of working people what
does that mean it means that we have got
to end the absurdity of being the only
major country on Earth not to guarantee
Health Care to all people Health Care is
a human right we pay twice as much per
capita on a healthcare because the
insurance companies make zillions of
dollars every single year
now you want to know what we should do
we should have the guts to take on the
pharmaceutical industry charges us 10
times more for particular drugs than the
people of any other country we should
raise the minimum wage to a living wage
we should expand Social Security because
half of the elderly people in this
country trying to get by a twenty five
thousand dollars a year you want a
strong country you want a great country
you make sure that every kid regardless
of income has the opportunity to get a
college education not leave school
deeply in debt that means making public
colleges and universities tuition-free
and you know what Tony every one of
these ideas is enormously popular
because we're going to pay for it right
by telling the billionaire class who in
some cases pay nothing in federal taxes
they're gonna have to start paying their
fair share do you know how majorities
get any of it done at the moment I guess
that's what it's about one way that
wages might go up and this goes to
working people as well is making College
more affordable there's a controversial
move right now from the Biden
Administration to forgive 400 billion
dollars according to CBO in student
loans you know most people in this
country still do not go to college so
that means that's a benefit for a
minority of us uh and it's controversial
where do you stand on it well at a time
when the Trump Administration gave a
trillion dollars in tax breaks to the
top one percent
and large corporations when you have
major corporations today some of the
biggest in this country make billions of
dollars a year in profit don't pay a
nickel in taxes you know what I think it
is appropriate to tell a younger
generation that in many ways
has a standard of living which is lower
than their parents that we are going to
help what was their crime they wanted to
go to college I have talked to people
Medical School nursing school leave
school a hundred thousand dollars in
debt that's insane so I think we need to
help those people but I think Tony the
point that we got to get back to we
don't talk about it on TV very much we
don't talk about any Congress very much
you got three people in America who are
more wealth than the bottom half of
American society gap between the very
rich and everybody else is growing wider
maybe just maybe we demand that the
people on top stop paying their fair
share of taxes
I I have a question for you about uh
aging because clearly you have not lost
your enthusiasm and I speak to you as a
fellow senior citizen there we go
somebody told me this morning let's get
into it well Gail you're a senior
citizen I go I am what's the definition
of a senior citizen anyone over the age
of 65 so you're 81 uh President Biden is
79 and there is a group of younger
politicians who say now is the time to
let the younger generation come through
and most Americans according to numerous
polls including the CBS poll say yes
there should be age limits and in fact
the older people support age limits more
than younger people yeah where are you
on that question Mr 81 year old
excuse me what did you say exactly
um look this is what I think you can
categorize everybody you know you're
different than everybody you know we're
all different yeah you got to look at
the individual but what I think we do
guys is we look too much at race agenda
at age what does somebody stand for yeah
what are their views do you agree with
them are they standing for you are they
standing for the big money interest and
obviously you want people who are
confident or capable of the energy I
mean by God to be president the United
States requires an enormous amount of
energy but I would say first of all take
a look at what people stand for
and we don't do that enough we're too
much into personality what people stand
for and what are their capabilities
right and I sit here I can't imagine
doing this job at 81 saying Tony Nate do
you have my sensible shoes I can't
imagine doing that but you know who
knows yeah but as you sit here at 81 and
Joe Biden's 79 do you think he should
run again for the presidency well that's
his decision uh I know it says Joe is a
friend of mine and I think against
enormous opposition he has tried to do
some very very uh good things and he
will make that decision himself but I
think again and you know you're not
going to hear this much on corporate
television if I may say something what
we need is Gail what we need is people
what I think that's his decision no
that's not that's his decision all right
what I think is we need millions of
people to start reclaiming their country
and demanding an economy that works for
all we have got to deal with the fact
oil companies huge profits food
companies huge profits what people can't
afford to fill up a tank of gas do you
plan to run again that's something you
know I haven't made that decision right
now my focus and I'll be going around
the country dealing with trying to elect
uh often young progressives often young
people of color yeah who are prepared to
stand up for working families and take
on big money interests I want to ask you
about the Democracy itself
they're having their last hearing this
week yeah um what have you seen tomorrow
what have you heard that has maybe given
you the idea that it could possibly
charge former president Trump well look
one of the saddest things you know in
politics I have conservative friends and
and I hope people respect each other
regardless of their political course of
course but what we have seen in recent
years as a Republican party move very
far to the right
uh and in many respects no longer
believe in democracy you know what
January 6 was about as an essential
essentially an attempt
to overturn the United States government
and prevent the guy who won the election
from taking office
well I know that's the way I see it I
was in the building at the time
most voters are worried about democracy
for the reasons they start throwing out
here so what can you do as a senator
what's your role in fixing it all right
now I'm going to give you a different
answer than other people do and my
answer is that right now A lot of people
are losing faith in government if you
were a worker out there yeah and you
your job went to China your job went to
Mexico you're making less than you used
to make your kid can't afford to go to
college you can't afford health care and
somebody puts a 30-second ad up on CB I
said vote for me he said go to hell
you're all the same you're not doing
anything for me you want to restore
democracy have a government that works
for ordinary people and it has to God so
by the way when you talk about politics
you understand that right now
billionaires are putting hundreds and
hundreds of millions of dollars into TV
as my advice to the viewers when you see
a TV ad kind of ask yourself which
billionaire is funding it and why what
do they want how many more tax breaks do
they want how much more corporate
welfare do they want ask that question
do you think all billionaires are bad no
I don't but I think when you have
enormous terrible and inequality in
America yeah when you got billionaires
buying islands and buying jet planes to
wake up people sleeping out on the
street I do not believe that is what
this country is supposed to be about so
again you're not going to hear it much
on corporate television I happen to
believe that we need redistribution of
wealth in this country we need to
protect the middle class and working
class and the billionaires cannot have
it all that's my view this phrase reduce
redistribution of wealth is not one you
hear from other Democrats no you don't
but you know what Tony this is an
important point there has been a massive
redistribution of wealth in the last 50
years did you know that
I among uh it's gone in the wrong
direction exactly Nate massive we're
talking about trillions of dollars going
into one percent while the working class
of the middle class become poorer we
have to deal with that issue I hear what
you're saying Senator Sanders thank you
so much thank you